I wait in line for the bathroom every time
I'm in public. Like, every time.
I'm a female, so I always wait
in line to use the bathroom.
(all talking)
Ahhh.
(crickets)
Narrator: For a typical busy bathroom,
women have to wait about
34 times as long as men.
But, contrary to some stereotypes,
it's not because they're busy chitchatting
or reapplying their makeup inside.
So then why is there always a
line for the women's restroom?
Women spend as much as twice
as long in the bathroom as men,
and that's because they menstruate,
they have more layers
of clothes to remove,
they always have to enter a stall,
and they're far more likely to have kids
or elderly people with them.
But these are just contributing factors
to a much larger problem.
Kathryn Anthony: Well, in
most of the building stock,
there are fewer fixtures for
women than there are for men.
Narrator: That's Kathryn
Anthony, a professor
of architecture at the
University of Illinois
at Urbana-Champaign.
Anthony: It is definitely a
subtle, but very powerful,
form of gender discrimination.
No question about that,
it is plain and simple.
There's no disguising it.
Narrator: She says that in many buildings,
the men's and women's
rooms are the same size,
but because urinals take up less space,
men's rooms have more toilets,
which contributes to less
waiting time for men.
To figure out just how much less,
queuing theorists at Ghent
University developed a model.
First, they considered bathrooms
that were the same size
where men have 12 toilets
and women have just 10.
Then, they accounted for the
time spent per bathroom visit
for women and men and
the speed of traffic.
The model showed that if someone
arrives every five seconds,
on average, women will
wait more than six minutes
while men will wait just 11 seconds.
So then what would a
better toilet ratio be?
Anthony: I would say the ratio should be
well more than 1 to 1.
Narrator: She's right.
According to this model,
the women's room should have
at least 50% more toilets
than the men's room,
as they show here.
Only then would men and women
have nearly equal wait times.
Now, the US is getting
closer to this target
thanks to the so-called
"potty parity" movement.
It took off in 1987 when
a California state senator
went to a Tchaikovsky concert
at the Hollywood Bowl.
There, he waited for
more than half an hour
for his wife to use the bathroom.
Anthony: He realized just
how long it took for her,
and that was unfair.
She complained, and he
complained and said,
"wait a minute, this isn't right."
Narrator: Soon after, he introduced a bill
to the California Senate, which demanded
more toilets for women in
large, new public buildings.
Anthony: That started a
wave of legislation across
some states and also
cities and municipalities.
Narrator: At least 21 states
and several cities have
since passed potty-parity policies.
In 2005, for example, New
York City passed legislation
that requires a 2-to-1
toilet ratio in places
of public assembly, such
as baseball stadiums.
But here's the thing: Even
where these laws exist,
you still find long lines
for the women's room,
and that's because they apply only
to buildings that are new or
undergoing major renovations,
which leaves thousands of older
buildings, such as theaters,
with too few toilets for women.
Sure, it's a hassle to wait,
but that's not the only problem.
Long term, it can actually
affect your health.
Anthony: A lot of women can end up
with urinary tract infections
and other kinds of health issues.
Narrator: So, what can be done?
Aside from waiting for
renovations or new construction,
there's a new trend:
gender-neutral bathrooms.
Anthony: That's a way
to alleviate the problem
of potty parity altogether,
so either nobody waits or everybody waits,
but you don't have one group
waiting more than another.
Narrator: And let's be real.
Women are already using the men's room.
If the line in the
women's room is too long,
I will never hesitate
to go to the men's room.
I probably go to the men's
room a couple times a year
when it's a dire situation.
I will literally go in the
men's bathroom probably more
than I will go in the
women's bathroom in New York.
I also use the men's room
a lot when I'm waiting.
Narrator: Because, well,
we all know the
alternative is a lot worse.